how's it going my name is Bev I kid you
alright
yes I am I know that guy is from
somewhere I know everyone in this game
from somewhere it's a high production
game to God actors in shape
anyhow Oh No clickers so what I figured
out and leaves is that Ellie can only
carry one weapon at a time I'm like
where's my [ __ ] weapon I kept looking
for it for a longest time anyway we're
gonna kill oh look a click it right
about ex-college oh no oh oh no my arrow
broke well we got eight of them so I
think we're thinking I think I think
we're okay okay it's got a cell through
this okay that could be a problem that
is a problem go up Ellie whoa Adam oh
[ __ ] oh okay are you asking me over the
clicker that way since s alkyl Ellie
you're too young we need to get up where
there okay how about you lift me up
well that that will work wow she really
looks like Ellen Page in that picture
and when she may yeah that's true go
Ellie yay this is the best game ever
okay you be quick keep a look up okay
Poppa pills knows what he's doing I
don't need okay we're fine the [ __ ] man
what have we got here more alcohol
I love o Firefly pendant I wonder where
if there's like a purpose of collecting
those
no anyway let's get the ladder bras
there we go
do you need a name like all like they're
together that's so cute
look at this oh look like they're
flirting with their legs like that's
adorable
are you done alright gotta stare out his
eyes nope there we go nice Ellie's butt
shot I didn't say nothin to you gasps
I'm ain't no kid I may look like a
fourteen-year-old girl but I am fourteen
and a half when you find a way out of
here whatever yeah no [ __ ] old man it's
the point of that that's his hello looks
like someone already fought those things
you lost more alcohol looking for these
boys
what's the matter had sex no thank you
sir can we craft them now yeah okay got
two of them is there any mala muder it
say any malam there it is I was looking
for you sir yeah that's what I'm doing
sir oh I'm ready all right
boom I'm so ready oh look here they are
just like I ordered them on eBay come at
me bro
I get his friend stopped working goddamn
kids and their twerking they never
[ __ ] stop twerking do they oh no not
the roof let me get some ammo no one no
one really well thanks shouldn't you
explode well that can't begin whoa [ __ ]
we got to go back in breath oh whoa whoa
whoa bad idea bad idea
Retreat I repeat there we go
fan-fucking-tastic let me pour it in my
own house okay
what's the other one
stay down
please Thanks how are you thanks it
brought me a present I love when they do
with that all right what's going on up
here
who [ __ ] put these health packs there
wow I guess jesus loves me after all oh
no no idea you're not welcome here you
neither your face especially what are
you doing
water you don't want water you don't
look at this pros they don't even know
what they're doing
oh thanks oh oh that doesn't sound very
good never mind
oh [ __ ] was animal how do I am i anyway
yeah oh nevermind nevermind nap huh oh
that's what is this oh no it's my mom
again mom you told me to leave me alone
this letsplay take this mom
that's right right in the head okay that
sounded low weird you might think that
sounded Allah
oh she can't fart when she's on fire
that's uh-oh she's behind me there's
someone behind me I'm out of here
hi all right let me don't you that's
Mike a woman who's making that way less
noise oh [ __ ] you can fart my mom has
superpowers
all right stop mom stop seriously see
they're not even that difficult I wish
it were a little harder maybe this is
because I use a mallet am i that was
four hey how you doing I think you're
full of your [ __ ] just word word homeboy
hello hi Ellie jumps is like [ __ ] yeah I
don't even get hey you want a private I
made it for you
listen easy party infected
oh no infected look at her hair what'd I
tell you
all right let's head on back check on
that bucket oh hi
don't touch my tents geez
don't trust that man yeah that creepy
hey yourself pretty nice back there huh
let's say we make a pretty good team
well yeah lucky oh yeah no no no such
thing as luck
oh now you see I believe and everything
happens for a reason okay
oh I don't share that scared to deck out
of me and I can prove it a [ __ ] owl
this winter that's been especially cruel
a few weeks back I am sent a group of
men out nearby town look for food uh-huh
only if you came back
he said that the others had been
slaughtered
I am crazy man what's crazy man that's
he's crazy man traveling a little girl
Oh Ali do something everything happens
for a reason
oh I'll get upset it's not your fault
I'm just a kid
let's shoot him James lower the gun no
way David I'm not gonna let her lower a
gun oh snap slay up now give her the
medicine yes I don't know about the
others won't be happy about this
well that's not your concern
I want Joel with a [ __ ] out of the way
come on Joel let me think survive long
out there I can't protect you no thanks
that was [ __ ] creepy [ __ ] that place
let's go back to Calais Calais is the
best character in this game he's
beautiful
let's get out of here good the bun is
still hanging around yeah [ __ ] yeah
come on
he's a Joel
Joel's yeah I better he bet him Joel
Helen rushed a little bit food but did
get this so he will live
he should get better pretty quick right
move your arm maybe not that looks like
a potato
here we go
like those zoomed in verify Oh glad it's
so cute she's taking care of all old
Joel you're gonna make it
oh that is aa thought Ellie you are
killing me with the cuteness right now
Oh
they [ __ ] followed us well what do you
think Kelly honestly I'm gonna draw them
away from here I'll come back for you
that really the best idea I mean they
could hide out pretty well and if
someone comes in it's [ __ ] stab bad
looks like something else okay why is it
so blue oldest on it what what is going
on how can they not hear she's here oh
no he did not
Oh David sir hey don't [ __ ] David
welcome gentlemen
hey calles wish oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
what you [ __ ] teleported get up but
don't teleport idiot you don't teleport
about in my holes huh I don't know them
to get too many okay oh oh I'm going
this way
why don't they just shoot the horse
their aim really sucks man okay
yeah that [ __ ] makes sense oh no no no I
was just kidding no she adores don't
your doors don't shoot the horse don't
you tell us please no calles calles and
your God you know you would pay for this
[ __ ] right you [ __ ] [ __ ]
come at me oh don't you dare how [ __ ]
dare you move blow your [ __ ] brains
out
[ __ ] that I'm coming back for your
callous yellow well I wonder if I can
blow that up feels like we have to go
down to funky town what is in this house
what's that I think it's time for that
alright found some [ __ ] so Ellie has
infinite ships apparently that creep
ones is alive huh James told me it's the
girl from the university how many of our
guys were killed there twelve and a hat
man you know those her screw David then
hey guys get a chance with this what's
that
my ass oh [ __ ] there was more of them
ooh we could do it but we can we
couldn't throw a party this way you guys
check that cabinet oh she's gonna she's
gonna shake the cabin
okay
come at me baby give me a best shot
and that's how you kill people oh I'll
take that thank you sir
it's a lotta ammo and whoa whoa
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] down man down
no no no you're saying you're saying
that that is that is the incorrect
assumption hello what he's not down at
all it's a miracle I am The Cure that's
why I knew it how many aren't um I just
[ __ ] take them out hello okay yeah
yeah yeah just keep doing arrows cuz
they're so [ __ ] many anyway and what
else I don't have Joel's upgraded oh
there he is hi oh hi hi why why was it
why didn't you say hi almost night why
do we go oh [ __ ] there's more of them
how about enough guys
okay all right that was a quick one a
little quickie as I like to call it
let's keep the stage approach should we
do a long shot
just for fun no no no it wasn't me come
on
it's Meili DDT I don't even know where I
am there this [ __ ] stupid and it's
your time to sleep and execute your
welcome was there anything else I don't
think so all right Lulu that that's a
good one anyway it's fun killing you
guys I actually enjoy that a lot
hopefully each other again sometime all
right let's see here okay I should get
me a nature trike okay cliff Duvall's
can we go here you got this girl so far
that's no no that's not even water bra
don't be a dumpy anger whoa this place
is beautiful
I would love to visit a place like they
may be one day in future I'm just saying
where the hell are we going yellow hole
okay I'm digging it they were doing it I
don't know why not I want to ship some
people now they're way too infinite
ships and [ __ ] ships and [ __ ] that one
looks beautiful water is always like how
you judge graphics and video games like
good water-based game ever
what do we got I can't see a damn thing
is blocking me
well we better take care of it then
Ellie this is one of those it's one of
these quality gameplay
like I don't get it are you suppose it
whoa are you supposed to feel like more
immersed by doing random [ __ ] to prolong
the gameplay like what 30 seconds what's
the point I don't I don't get it I don't
really get it but hey I'm not the one
making calls and actually okay sleep ak
we're hanging there Joel it's place
looks cool I wonder if they have a
skiing resort or some [ __ ] like that
oh [ __ ] there they are more of them
let's see if we can do a quick stealth
around them why would I hide we're such
good friends look at these idiots I
don't even know what Oh Shh we can
totally take that guy out though oh how
many [ __ ] are there it's like a
[ __ ] baby boom ha ha I never get
tired of that I hope there's no more
though oh [ __ ] what is he gonna do
he's gonna wear a bottle of shampoo see
I lost some I'm okay
okay oh [ __ ] look at this idiot
yeah alright let's get up here looks
like a way inside I don't want to get
trapped in here did she say they see us
no I didn't they don't see us they don't
know what they don't win I know nobody's
knowing I check out those five whichever
way the wind is blowing we are falling
everything as always especially full on
life
I don't like LA with a shotgun she's not
really good with it but I feel like we
should waste some ammo with it thanks
game you're too kind
[ __ ] it let's go with this one
hi careful oh [ __ ] you don't you ever
try to pull a fast one on me no bombing
ain't nobody pull a fast one and piss
and their sex [ __ ] what do they want
what do you want
was that it
here you done now can I go okay finally
here we go can we do this can we do it
get out of here box Yosh come on Ellie
Ellie doesn't look too pregnant right
now so what it's all that matters
Oh che
dude so they eat the dead bodies that is
[ __ ] nice that only got come on oh
you can think of something how are you
feeling how did he know we were gonna
wake up here that she did yeah that
looks nasty I know you're hungry been
out for quite some time
what is it
it's dear
with some human helping on the side yeah
no no I promise it's just the deer meat
what is he wine I don't understand and
then she you think looks like pancakes
would quick to judgment tomato though
considering you and your friend killed
how many men they didn't give us a
choice
and you think we have a choice is that
it yeah I think so
you to survive no no no your guys honest
we would be like its tier of our own by
any means necessary
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] us so now what
you gonna chop me up into tiny pieces
I'd rather not please tell me your name
you're so full of [ __ ]
on the contrary I've been yep kiss me
quite honest with you
now I think it's your turn it's the only
way I'm gonna be able to convince the
others kind of in some of what that you
can come around that's hard why no one
you're special
uh-oh Oh uh-oh
man no dude dude don't hit on a
fourteen-year-old Avera that's a wrong I
don't want oh oh oh Kelly hey what are
you doing Oh where's dole stupid little
girl hiiii
miss click you are making it very
difficult to keep you alive
where am I supposed to tell the others
now but you tripped on the deer Ellie
what tell them that Ellie is the little
girl I broke your [ __ ] finger what a
little often mileage you put it huh
tiny pieces ooh Joel Jolie in the Hornet
alley
you better wake up Joel
he's a badass but joel is badass level
12 so ah
Oh see his belly is a potato he doesn't
even give a [ __ ] yeah that's shit's
gotta hurt is he bleeding heli
that looks heavy all right cool
wha it's that [ __ ] mole again hello
I'm not scared of insects I'm a macho
man like John just gonna [ __ ] kill it
how are you
oh that it's not a pretty sight on the
wall
okay anyhow not I'm a macho man I'm
badass like door insects why would they
scare me seriously
I'm some tough really uh-oh shouldn't
there be bad guys and stuff like that
piss all this game puppy we have our
stuff this is very good news even the
Betty oh [ __ ] hey come on man
where is she better talk your dad uh
don't let him get you does that mean are
you running oh you guys like running I
love running they [ __ ] suck if they
like okay oh sure
hi careful oh I want that your guide
I want your again stop running
I just want a hug you know how long is
Bin's is a proper hug like [ __ ] face
do you know what that [ __ ] Oh chop meee
thank you
- ramat it I'm curious what happens if
you modded cuz I never minded it
alrights try it out on someone got your
ass oh you guys like barbecue well you
could totally have one with yourself
that's what you guys we're thinking you
got me a bunch of idiots
no one got pants cuz pigs got his
brothers meaning a lot all right Lou
where the hell is Alan oh oh yeah [ __ ]
Jolie's better tell me where she is
oh we're gonna party I wanted to do this
so much Jonas right
you wait here
now are we gonna torture them the girl
is she alive
what girl I don't know no girl really
you want to play that game right here
right here topic goddamn day off the
girl yeah laughs she's Davis newest fad
but where did it Sam
which [ __ ] pound you're gonna mark it
on the map and it better be the same
exact spot your buddy points to market
right there you can verify it go ask him
that's smart cool huh - hey line hey
Joel calm down
[ __ ] young man told you choose one yeah
Joel come on [ __ ]
that's all right I believe in not
waiting right Oh Joel I don't like that
you or I can it oh no bueno
I warned you I'm infected
really
so are you oh yeah she bit him my sleep
look at it I'll play long oh yeah she
bit him so she can still spread it is
that it oh and she's tricking him she's
drinking it what'd you say everything
happens for a reason right
allele Manny she would have turned by
now it can't be real looks pretty
[ __ ] real to me wow that's my girl
Oh Oh big thingy how you doing
why don't they give us deer if they had
like a big isn't she I understand that's
our switch plane it's time to play cat
and mouse Wow
we don't even need you'll see I like
that l is a badass on her own oh he's
wrong with these people
well hey calm down I need a good okay
we'll find one don't worry that is a
health pack we don't need that okay
gotcha
here we go it was Joel
all right this is birdcages effective
the girl she's infected and she got out
all Technic it's the shelter [ __ ] the
kids
that is messed up girl all right time to
kick a bad ass
let's clean this mess up then we could
have a town meeting Oh Rick Apple hey
Rick
Laura I saw a pop good night you like
knives knives well I think Ellie was a
mass murderer in another life or some
[ __ ] like that that's pretty [ __ ] up
check down there yeah I usually works
you want to come in my house
wait I can't realize he's coming well a
few years ago the nighttime Wow
well you died in me blood samurai that's
a great movie whoa second you can't see
me and that's why you die I like your
jacket
I got a poop in it
look around over here check over there
can you freeze to death if you stay out
too long we should say on target
that voice sounds so raspy and sexy I
mean what does it help if we're close to
the barrel no almost there almost at
rest we can do this hey flowers how the
hell did you survive where I can't see
anyone up that's suppose cuz I don't see
anyone
what is it yeah what is it talking about
all right I think I guess we're doing a
good job I don't even know it's I can't
see anything
uh-huh hey car oh hello so I guess in
here sure feels like it
discover those other people who were
going I bet that's like a cool place
what do you know about that
oh [ __ ] this game is awesome
bottom jeans bucks with the fur the
whole club is looking at huh how long do
we have to do this stealth mission
great what about here
oh this is their this is quite nice I
don't like this place it's gonna be
people Stephanie is gonna be a shootout
in this place look at I what was that Oh
where's Joel Julie alright
why nowhere to go oh you won't have my
welcome
I will come for them oh you're not
infected no one s infected whoops
stop following me I'm walking on the
plate no no your oh did he [ __ ] burn
the place okay he doesn't know where we
are anymore
[ __ ] my mate no I didn't
what is he doing is he drunk come on
hello well that was good kid yeah oh you
want to play you want a beer play big
fries and me
stop following me a minute I'm innocent
[ __ ] is that a skunk that is awesome
it's never too late okay here we go
go Ellie make your move bum-bum-bum
right in the butt
how does that feel but I ain't no
robbing I am at odds Tavis
where is it going now why do you keep if
just stop moving that would be a lot
easier oh oh hell hell yes
bye bye I don't pull a woman's hair
what what